I was a reporter for years in the Chicago Public schools, covering all the different ways that people tried to fix and improve those schools. And one of the big debates-- not just among the parents and politicians, but inside the schools as well-- was how much could we expect teachers to actually accomplish? Like, how much could they do, really, with the students they were given?
我曾在芝加哥公立学校当了多年记者，报道过人们尝试修复和改善这些学校的各种方法。其中一个重大的辩论——不仅是在家长和政客之间，甚至在学校内部——就是我们到底能期望老师取得多大的成就？也就是说，面对分给他们的学生，他们真的能做到什么程度？
Some teachers definitely were the heroic we-can-do-better types. We need to try everything. They were trying all kinds of reforms and fixes to make their schools improve. Others shrugged.
有些老师绝对是那种充满英雄主义的“我们可以做得更好”的类型。我们需要尝试一切。他们尝试了各种各样的改革和补救措施来改善学校。其他人则耸耸肩。
This population of kids, they would tell you, arrives with such deficits-- no books at home, violent neighborhoods, the kind of family problems that would distract anybody from school. These teachers would say, we're doing as well with them as anybody could. You know, if dozens of kids show up in your classroom each year with terrible reading ability and in need of remedial writing instruction, how exactly are you supposed to bring them up to grade level on the state standardized tests in the one year you have with them?
他们会告诉你，这群孩子入学时就带着各种缺陷——家里没有书、身处暴力社区、家庭问题足以让任何人无法专注于学业。这些老师会说，我们能教到这种程度已经是尽力了。你知道，如果每年有几十个孩子带着糟糕的阅读能力进入你的课堂，而且需要补习写作指导，在这一年的时间里，你究竟该如何让他们达到州标准化考试的年级水平呢？
One of the things that's been interesting about the teacher's strike in the Chicago schools is that it's actually gotten people talking about some very basic things in education, and things like these. Like for instance, one of the big issues is standardized testing. How much should teachers be evaluated on the test scores of their students? Where you stand on that one pretty much comes down to whether you think that teachers have a lot of power to raise those scores or not.
关于芝加哥学校教师罢工，有趣的一点是，它确实让人们开始讨论教育中一些非常基础的问题。例如，其中一个大问题是标准化考试。教师应该在多大程度上根据学生的考试成绩来接受评估？你在这个问题上的立场很大程度上取决于你认为老师在提高这些分数方面是否有很大的影响力。
There's an essay that's being published this Sunday in the New York Times by Alex Kotlowitz, a reporter who writes a lot about kids and poverty in Chicago. And he points out how much we expect from teachers, especially teachers in a school system like Chicago's where 87% of the students come from low income families. He writes that he's been reporting in a high school lately where the staff has transformed and improved the school in lots of ways.
本周日《纽约时报》将刊登亚历克斯·科特洛维茨（Alex Kotlowitz）的一篇文章，他是一位经常报道芝加哥儿童和贫困问题的记者。他指出，我们对老师的期望太高了，特别是在芝加哥这样的学校系统里，87%的学生来自低收入家庭。他写道，他最近在报道一所高中，那里的教职员工在很多方面对学校进行了改造和改善。
"And yet each day I spend there," he writes, "I witness one heartbreaking scene after another. A young girl who yells at one of the school's social workers, 'This is no way to live,' and then breaks down in tears. Because of problems at home, she's had to move in with a friend's family, and there's not enough food to go around. A young man has retreated into his shell having witnessed a murder over the summer.
“然而，我每天在那里度过，”他写道，“我目睹了一个又一个令人心碎的场景。一个小女孩对着学校的一名社会工作者喊道：‘这根本不是人过的日子，’然后泪流满面。因为家庭问题，她不得不搬到朋友家住，家里食物都不够吃。一个年轻人因为在夏天目睹了一起谋杀案，从此变得封闭自己。”
The stories are all too familiar. And yet somehow, we've come to believe that with really good teachers and longer school days and rigorous testing, we can transform their lives. We've imagined teachers as lazy, excuse-making quasi-professionals or, alternately, as lifesavers. But the truth, of course, is more complicated."
这些故事太熟悉了。然而不知何故，我们开始相信，只要有真正优秀的老师、更长的在校时间和严格的考试，我们就能改变他们的生活。我们将老师想象成懒惰、找借口、半吊子的专业人士，或者反过来，将他们视为救世主。但事实当然要复杂得多。
I bring all this up here today because there is a new way to look at all this, a new body of science that's just starting to get discussed in a widespread way. It looks at what a difficult home life can do to the brain of a school kid-- literally to the biology of the brain-- and how it makes it difficult to learn.
我今天之所以提起这些，是因为有一种看待这一切的新视角，一套新的科学理论刚刚开始被广泛讨论。它着眼于艰难的家庭生活会对学龄儿童的大脑产生什么影响——甚至是字面意义上的大脑生物学影响——以及它是如何导致学习困难的。
And this science suggests all kinds of things that schools could be doing that could improve teaching, get through to huge numbers of kids that teachers have a hard time getting through to today.
而这门科学表明，学校可以做各种各样的事情来改善教学，接触到那些老师目前难以触及的广大孩子。
As school starts up again, we thought here at the radio show that it would be nice to turn away from the political questions and the union questions and the money questions and all the regular stuff that people argue about when they argue about schools all the time and turn instead today for the beginning of school to something more optimistic and forward-looking, something that feels big and Earth-shaking and, I have to say, kind of exciting. That is what we're going to be talking about today.
随着学校再次开学，我们在广播节目中认为，与其讨论政治问题、工会问题、资金问题以及人们在谈论学校时总是争论的所有常规话题，不如在开学之际谈谈一些更乐观、更有前瞻性的内容，一些感觉宏大、震撼人心，而且我不得不说，令人兴奋的事情。这就是我们今天要谈论的内容。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。请继续收听。
Act One-- No, These Things Will Not Be on the Final Exam. OK, so let's start with the most basic question, a question that is so big, it is almost embarrassing to ask out loud. What should kids be learning at school?
第一幕——不，这些内容不会出现在期末考试中。好吧，让我们从最基本的问题开始，这个问题太大了，说出来甚至有点尴尬。孩子们在学校应该学什么？
You know, people argue about this. Schools are established pushing this approach or that one about the best way to teach. And I learned about this shift in the way that people are answering this question, this whole new set of theories and ideas that are in the air right now from this new book, this book that came out this month that is trying to document that shift and explain what these ideas are about.
你知道，人们对此争论不休。学校建立起来是为了推行这种或那种教学方法。我从一本这个月刚出版的新书里了解到了人们回答这个问题的方式正在发生转变，这是一套全新的理论和观点，旨在记录这种转变并解释这些想法是什么。
Some of these ideas have been around for years but are now backed up by new data and tied to research about what goes on in kids' brains. Some are new, based on new research.
其中一些想法已经存在多年，但现在有了新的数据支持，并与关于儿童大脑运作的研究联系在一起。有些则是基于新研究的新观点。
There are educators involved in this, psychologists, economists, neuroscientists. They're not all working together. But they're starting to make connections. And I feel like they're coming to a similar conclusion.
参与其中的有教育工作者、心理学家、经济学家、神经科学家。他们并非都在一起工作，但他们开始建立联系，而且我觉得他们正在得出相似的结论。
This is Paul Tough. He's a reporter who writes about new approaches to educating children. He's been on our program now and then in the past. And he's the one who wrote this new book.
这是保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。他是一位报道教育儿童新方法的记者。他过去曾偶尔出现在我们的节目中，也是这本书的作者。
He says that to understand this shift in thinking, you have to first understand where things were before the shift. Up until now, what's been emphasised in most schools is something called-- and jargon word here, but there's no way around this-- something they call cognitive development.
他说，要理解这种思维的转变，首先必须了解转变之前的情况。到目前为止，大多数学校强调的是一种被称为——这里用个术语，但无法避免——所谓“认知发展”的东西。
And what "cognitive development" means is smarts the way that you think about smarts in school-- the stuff that gets measured on IQ tests and standardized math and reading achievement tests that kids take most places. And it's not like that stuff isn't important.
而“认知发展”的意思就是聪明才智，也就是你在学校里认为的聪明才智——即智商测试以及孩子们在大多数地方参加的标准化数学和阅读成绩测试中所衡量的东西。并不是说这些东西不重要。
Well, I'm definitely not saying that none of that stuff matters at all. I'm saying that we have put way too much emphasis on it, and especially in the early years. I think it's especially parents of very young kids who get really anxious that their kids need all of these skills and all of this information really early on. I think--
嗯，我绝对不是说这些东西完全不重要。我是说我们对它的强调太过分了，特别是在早年阶段。我认为特别是那些非常年幼孩子的家长，他们非常焦虑，觉得孩子需要很早就掌握所有这些技能和信息。我想——
There's a whole industry that came out of that.
由此产生了一个完整的产业链。
Exactly. I think it's part of these preschool classes, Junior Kumon, all of these flash cards and brain building toys and the right kind of videos and DVDs from early on to try to boost their cognitive skills at an earlier and earlier age.
没错。我认为这是学前班、幼儿公文式学习法（Junior Kumon）、所有这些闪示卡、健脑玩具以及从早期就开始提供的各种正确类型的视频和DVD的一部分，试图在越来越小的年龄提升他们的认知技能。
So that's the old way of looking at this. What's our new understanding?
所以那是看待这个问题的旧方式。我们新的理解是什么？
Where I think they're heading is this idea that what matters most in a child's success is not just cognitive skill. It's not just reading and math and IQ. It is this very different set of qualities.
我认为他们的方向是这种想法：孩子成功最重要的不仅是认知技能。不仅仅是阅读、数学和智商。而是一套完全不同的品质。
And you write that the guy who's kind of at the heart of this way of thinking is an economist named Heckman, right?
你写道，这种思维方式的核心人物是一位名叫赫克曼（Heckman）的经济学家，对吧？
Yeah, James Heckman. He's a Nobel Prize winning economist at the University of Chicago. If there's any one figure who is trying to pull together all of this research, it's him. He puts together these conferences where he invites psychologists and neuroscientists and economists, people who don't usually have much connection, to get together and talk about some of these ideas and some of these issues.
是的，詹姆斯·赫克曼（James Heckman）。他是芝加哥大学的诺贝尔经济学奖得主。如果说有哪个人试图将所有这些研究汇集在一起，那就是他。他组织了一些会议，邀请心理学家、神经科学家和经济学家，这些平时没什么交集的人聚在一起，讨论其中一些想法和议题。
The thing that really got Heckman started down this path was a study that he did about the GED.
让赫克曼真正走上这条路的是他做的一项关于同等学力证书（GED）的研究。
The GED, of course, is the high school equivalency exam. If you didn't graduate from high school, you can take the GED. And if you pass, it counts the same as if you graduated.
GED当然是高中同等学力考试。如果你没有从高中毕业，你可以参加GED考试。如果你通过了，就等同于高中毕业。
Well, I'll give you-- it's a personal anecdote. This was in the early 1990s.
嗯，我给你讲个个人轶事。这是在20世纪90年代初。
When I invited Heckman into the studio to chat, he told me how blown away he was when he first encountered the GED. It was the early 1990s, like he said. He was in Texas doing a study about something else.
当我邀请赫克曼到演播室聊天时，他告诉我他第一次接触GED时是多么震惊。那是20世纪90年代初，正如他所说。他在德克萨斯州做另一项研究。
And they pointed to this classroom and said, "You realize that these people will be studying for their GEDs. And in a few weeks, maybe a few months, you can convert essentially high school dropouts, people who were even intermediate school dropouts, into high school graduates." And I said, "That's amazing."
他们指着这间教室说：“你意识到这些人将要学习GED了吗？几周，也许几个月后，你基本上就可以把高中辍学生，甚至是初中辍学生，变成高中毕业生。”我说：“这太不可思议了。”
So I'm an economist. And that really started to surprise me. And as a result--
所以我是个经济学家，这真的让我开始感到惊讶。结果——
Wait, why was that surprising if what they were testing was just you've learned this information?
等等，如果他们测试的只是你学到了这些信息，那为什么会令人惊讶呢？
Well, it was surprising, you know, in a few months, you could actually teach people the knowledge that they would acquire in four years of high school.
嗯，令人惊讶的是，你知道，在几个月内，你居然可以教给人们他们在四年高中里学到的知识。
Oh, I see.
哦，我明白了。
Maybe a couple more. So it seemed to me-- really, the average preparation time for a GED is like 32 hours. And the average amount of study time for a student in high school is around 1,000 hours per year. And you say, "Well, wait, that's like 3,000, 4,000 hours versus 32." And from an economic standpoint, if that were true, it would be a real miracle. And it would be very cost effective. All eighth graders should take the GEDs.
也许再多几个月。所以在我看来——实际上，GED的平均准备时间大约是32小时。而高中生平均学习时间每年大约是1000小时。你说，“好吧，等等，那是3000到4000小时对比32小时。”从经济学角度看，如果这是真的，那将是一个真正的奇迹，而且非常有成本效益。所有八年级学生都应该参加GED考试。
Instead of going to high school?
而不是去上高中？
Instead of going to high school.
而不是去上高中。
We would save ourselves a lot of money.
我们会节省很多钱。
Save ourselves a lot of money. Save ourselves a lot of time.
节省很多钱。节省很多时间。
So Heckman kept thinking about this. If it were true, should we even have high school? It raised some questions. Which led him to wonder, well, is it really true that the GED was equivalent to graduating from high school? Did the GED students really go on to do as well as the graduating high school students in life?
所以赫克曼一直在思考这个问题。如果这是真的，我们甚至应该有高中吗？这引起了一些疑问。这让他开始怀疑，GED真的等同于高中毕业吗？GED学生在生活中真的能像高中毕业生那样表现出色吗？
So he devised a study that looked at what happened over time to people with GEDs versus people who graduated from high school.
于是他设计了一项研究，观察GED持有者与高中毕业生随着时间推移的情况。
And so when we follow these people into adult life, follow them many years, what we found was consistently GEDs are performing slightly better than dropouts who didn't go on and take the GED, people who really dropped out of high school, but nowhere near as well as high school graduates. And that was in terms of performance in earnings, performance in occupation.
所以当我们跟踪这些人进入成年生活，跟踪多年后，我们发现GED持有者的表现始终略好于那些没有去考GED的辍学生，也就是真正的高中辍学生，但远远不如高中毕业生。这体现在收入表现和职业表现上。
We find that they consistently fail, whether it's going on in college. The success rates in college are very low. The success rates in the military are very low. The success rates in marriage are very low. They get married, but they drop out of marriage. These people drop out of virtually everything they start.
我们发现他们始终表现不佳，无论是上大学。上大学的成功率很低。参军的成功率很低。婚姻的成功率很低。他们会结婚，但婚姻会破裂。这些人几乎退出了他们开始的所有事情。
Now, if you think about it, this shouldn't be so surprising. If you can't manage to follow the rules and do what's assigned and keep your ass in a chair for four years of high school, of course you might be somebody who has trouble applying yourself later in life. Of course, you might be different from a high school grad.
现在，如果你想想，这不应该令人惊讶。如果你不能设法遵守规则，完成布置的任务，并且在高中坚持坐四年冷板凳，那么你当然可能是一个在以后的生活中难以努力的人。当然，你可能与高中毕业生有所不同。
But what struck Heckman is that this didn't show up in the test results. Our entire education system is organized around the idea that testing and the kind of smarts that you can measure on a test, are the most important information we could have about a student. That's how we evaluate whether a school is well-run. There are kids  who do better on standardized tests. That's at the heart of huge policy initiatives, like No Child Left Behind.
但让赫克曼感到震惊的是，这并没有在测试结果中显示出来。我们整个教育系统都是围绕着一个想法组织的：测试和你在测试中衡量的聪明才智是我们能拥有的关于学生的最重要的信息。这就是我们评估学校是否管理得当的方式。有些孩子在标准化测试中表现更好。这是重大政策举措的核心，比如《不让一个孩子掉队》（No Child Left Behind）。
But here was a test, the GED, that said that millions of people were just as smart as high school graduates. If they passed the GED, it proved that their cognitive skills were just as good. But these people were failing, which led Heckman to conclude--
但这里有一个测试，GED，它声称数百万人和高中毕业生一样聪明。如果他们通过了GED，证明他们的认知技能同样好。但这些人却在失败，这导致赫克曼得出结论——
That these test scores explain only a tiny fraction of the variability among individuals-- who's successful and who's not-- and that other factors are out there that aren't measured that aren't even accounted for in public policy that make a big difference. And so I said, "Hm, something's missing."
这些测试分数仅能解释个体差异的一小部分——谁成功谁不成功——还有其他未被衡量的因素，甚至在公共政策中未被考虑到的因素，起到了巨大的作用。所以我说，“嗯，少了点什么。”
And now, the first impulse is you appeal to astrophysics and you say, ah dark matter. There's something out there in the universe that we're missing. And that dark matter, what could it be?
现在，第一反应是你求助于天体物理学，你会说，啊，暗物质。宇宙中有些东西是我们遗漏的。而那暗物质可能是什么？
What were the skills that the GED students lacked that the high school graduates had? Specifically, what was this unnamed dark matter, and how could you measure it? Heckman started calling these mystery skills that he was looking for non-cognitive skills to distinguish them from the stuff that educators normally focused on, which of course were cognitive skills.
GED学生缺乏而高中毕业生拥有的技能是什么？具体来说，这种未命名的暗物质是什么，你如何衡量它？赫克曼开始将他寻找的这些神秘技能称为“非认知技能”，以区别于教育工作者通常关注的内容，也就是认知技能。
But it must be a drag saying the phrase "non-cognitive skills" all the time because when you talk to Heckman, over the course of a conversation, he jumps around to all kinds of other words to describe the same thing.
但是一直说“非认知技能”这个词一定很烦人，因为当你和赫克曼交谈时，在对话过程中，他会跳跃到各种其他词汇来描述同样的事情。
Soft skills.
软技能。
Or a moment later.
或者是稍后提到的。
Social skills.
社交技能。
Or here's another.
或者还有另一个。
Personality traits.
人格特质。
You know what you guys need is you need a better word for this.
你知道你们需要的是一个更好的词。
Better word? "Non-cognitive" is not good, you mean?
更好的词？你是说“非认知”不好吗？
No. The phrase "non-cognitive skills," it just feels a little confusing or clumsy.
不。“非认知技能”这个词感觉有点令人困惑或笨拙。
I agree with you. It's lousy. It sounds like a very negative terminology.
我同意你的看法。它很糟糕。听起来像是一个非常消极的术语。
Well, it's funny talking to you about it. Because even as you talk about, I hear you run through all the different terms, because none seems to suit.
嗯，和你讨论这个很有趣。因为即使你在谈论它时，我也听到你用了各种不同的词，因为似乎没有一个词是合适的。
Correct.
没错。
Because you guys haven't come up with a term yet.
因为你们还没想出一个术语。
Well, no, we have-- character. Character. The trouble is "character" sounds very moralistic. It sounds like we're running a Sunday School. See, I think the proper word is probably personality and social skills.
嗯，不，我们有——品格。品格。麻烦的是“品格”听起来非常道德说教。听起来像是在办主日学。你看，我认为合适的词可能是个性和社交技能。
Listen to you! You're changing from minute to minute.
听听你说的！你每分钟都在变。
I agree, I agree. We go all over it.
我同意，我同意。我们一直在反复讨论。
Heckman says it's not like educators never considered character before this-- or should I say non-cognitive skills? The history of American schools is a pendulum that swings between emphasizing character on the one hand and intelligence on the other. Everything from classical boarding schools to progressive schools to modern private schools have endeavored to teach character, not just the ABCs.
赫克曼说，这并不是说教育工作者在这之前从未考虑过品格——或者我应该说非认知技能？美国学校的历史就像一个钟摆，在一端强调品格，在另一端强调智力。从古典寄宿学校到进步学校再到现代私立学校，一切都在努力教授品格，而不仅仅是ABC。
And public schools once taught character-- conduct, deportment. Those are the words they used, which Heckman would call non-cognitive skills. But over the course of the 20th century, testing-- standardized testing of math and reading and other cognitive skills-- grew and it grew until it dominated American education.
公立学校曾经教导品格——行为举止。那是他们使用的词，赫克曼会称之为非认知技能。但到了20世纪，测试——数学和阅读以及其他认知技能的标准化测试——不断增长，直到它统治了美国教育。
What happened-- and this is just the logic of testing, how tests have a life of their own. But literally what happened was it became very easy to mark reading, writing tests much harder to judge deportment, to judge all these other traits. It's hard as hell to measure those.
发生了什么——这只是测试的逻辑，测试是如何拥有自己生命的。但实际上发生的是，评估阅读和写作测试变得非常容易，而判断品格、判断所有这些其他特质则困难得多。衡量这些东西难如登天。
And so most schools gradually organized themselves around teaching stuff that you can measure, stuff you can quantify in test results, which are the cognitive skills. All this other stuff went by the wayside.
所以大多数学校逐渐围绕着教授那些你可以衡量的东西来组织自己，那些可以在测试结果中量化的东西，也就是认知技能。所有这些其他东西都被抛弃了。
Now, Heckman wanted to take a look at it anew. And specifically, he was interested in finding skills that he could prove, empirically prove, help kids succeed-- and succeed in the ways that an economist measure success. Things like how much money do you earn, and do you end up in prison, and are you on welfare? And he then wanted to try to understand how these things could be taught.
现在，赫克曼想重新审视它。具体来说，他有兴趣寻找那些他可以证明、经得起经验证明能够帮助孩子成功的东西——并且是以经济学家衡量成功的方式取得成功。比如你挣多少钱，你是否最终入狱，你是否靠福利生活？然后他想尝试了解这些东西是如何被教授的。
For such a prominent academic, a Nobel Prize winner, to tackle all this and tackle all this in this way was new. Nobody set out on a mission like the one that Heckman now embarked on, pulling in and connecting people who were already working on pieces of the puzzle. Again, Paul Tough.
对于一位如此杰出的学者、诺贝尔奖得主来说，以这种方式处理这一切是全新的。没有人像赫克曼现在所做的那样，设定一个任务，去汇集和联系那些已经在研究拼图碎片的人们。再次重申，保罗·塔夫。
And that's what he's been doing for the last 10 years.
这就是他过去10年来一直在做的事情。
And so as the research has gone on, what kinds of things have people found are these non-cognitive skills? Like, what are they?
那么随着研究的进行，人们发现什么样的东西是这些非认知技能？比如，它们是什么？
Well, there's not sort of a master list of non-cognitive skills right now. The ones that Heckman would refer to and that I think are most important, some of them have to do with self-control. There's a number of different terms-- things like self-regulation skills, self-control, conscientiousness. So that, I think, is one set of things. Just the ability to delay gratification, to resist impulse. When you're about to make a bad decision, to think twice about it. To keep your temper. All of those things, I think, matter a lot.
嗯，目前还没有一张非认知技能的清单。赫克曼会提到而且我认为最重要的一些，有些与自我控制有关。有许多不同的术语——比如自我调节技能、自我控制、尽责性。所以，我认为这是一类东西。只是延迟满足的能力，抵制冲动的能力。当你即将做出一个糟糕决定时，三思而行。控制你的脾气。我认为所有这些都很重要。
And I feel like when you say that, it makes me think of studies that I think a lot of us have read about where they'll put a kid into a room. And they have to resist eating a cookie, something like that.
而且我觉得当你这么说时，让我想起了我们很多人读过的研究，他们会把一个孩子关进房间。他们必须抵制吃掉一块饼干，诸如此类的事情。
Yeah, this is called the marshmallow test. And this is a famous test that was done starting back in the 1960s by a psychology professor then at Stanford named Walter Mischel. And he took a bunch of four-year-olds into a room, said, "Here is a marshmallow or a cookie. I'm going to leave the room. If you want, you can just ring this bell, and I'll come back, and I'll give you one of this treat. But if you can wait until I come back on my own, then you get two." And so this was like psychological torture for these kids.
是的，这叫棉花糖测试。这是斯坦福大学一位心理学教授沃尔特·米歇尔（Walter Mischel）从20世纪60年代开始做的一个著名实验。他把一群四岁的孩子带进房间，说：“这有一块棉花糖或饼干。我要离开房间。如果你愿意，你可以按这个铃，我会回来，然后给你一块。但如果你能等到我回来，那你就得到两块。”这简直是对这些孩子的心理折磨。
They were four.
他们才四岁。
Exactly. And so they would sit there and try to resist ringing this bell.
没错。所以他们会坐在那里试图抵制按下铃的冲动。
And squirm.
而且坐立不安。
Exactly. It was very painful for them.
没错。这对他们来说非常痛苦。
[WAILS] It's so long!
[哭喊] 时间太长了！
This is such a well-known study that on YouTube, you can see videos that various parents have made administering this test to their own kids in their own homes.
这是一个如此知名的研究，以至于在YouTube上，你可以看到各种家长在自己家中对孩子进行这个测试的视频。
10 minutes. 10 minutes! 10 minutes! 10 minutes!
10分钟。10分钟！10分钟！10分钟！
This little boy named Theo has obviously been told that he's going to get his second treat if he can just wait 10 minutes. And he sits there.
这个名叫西奥（Theo）的小男孩显然被告知，如果他能等上10分钟，他就会得到第二块零食。于是他坐在那里。
10 minutes! 10 minutes! 10 minutes! 10 minutes! 10 minutes! Aw, 10 minutes!
10分钟！10分钟！10分钟！10分钟！10分钟！哎，10分钟！
So anyway, back to Walter Mischel.
总之，回到沃尔特·米歇尔。
He was actually doing this study to try to figure out how kids resisted temptation. And it was only like 10 and 15 and 20 years down the road when he started looking these kids up again, and he wanted to find out how well they were doing.
他其实做这项研究是为了找出孩子们是如何抵制诱惑的。直到10年、15年、20年后，当他开始再次寻找这些孩子，想要了解他们现在过得如何时。
And he found there were these huge correlations between how long these kids had been able to wait for the treat and how well they did on their SATs, how much money they were making, all sorts of indicators of how well they were doing in life.
他发现这些孩子等待零食的时间长短与他们在SAT考试中的表现、他们赚多少钱以及生活中表现良好的各种指标之间存在巨大的相关性。
Now, for James Heckman, and for writer Paul Tough for that matter, what is most exciting about the power of these non-cognitive skills is the possibility they would give kids the skills they need to get out of poverty and the skills they need in the short run to counter-act the effects of poverty on children in school.
现在，对于詹姆斯·赫克曼，以及作者保罗·塔夫来说，这些非认知技能的力量最令人兴奋的是，它们有可能让孩子们获得摆脱贫困所需的技能，以及在短期内抵消贫困对在校儿童影响的技能。
It's well-documented that poor children do worse on tests and worse in school than better-off ones. This is the so-called achievement gap.
有据可查的是，贫困儿童在测试和学校中的表现比富裕家庭的孩子差。这就是所谓的成就差距。
What this new science seems to indicate is that what is holding these children back is not poverty. It's not the lack of money or resources in their homes. It's stress. If you grew up in a poor household, it is more likely to be a household the just stresses you out in ways that kids in better-off homes are not stressed out. And that stress prevents you from developing these non-cognitive skills.
这项新科学似乎表明，阻碍这些孩子的不是贫困。不是他们家里缺乏金钱或资源。而是压力。如果你在贫困家庭长大，它更有可能是一个让你倍感压力的家庭，而富裕家庭的孩子不会有这种压力。这种压力阻止了你发展这些非认知技能。
What was stumping me was how does this work.
让我困惑的是，这到底是怎么运作的。
Let me introduce you to somebody else that Paul Tough writes about in his book. This is Dr. Nadine Burke Harris. In 2007, she set up a clinic for children in Bayview-Hunters Point in San Francisco. And she set it up there because poor, minority communities like that one are often less healthy than other communities. She was an idealistic, young, black doctor. And she wanted to do something about that. She also had a master's degree in public health. But stress and its effects on kids wasn't on her radar yet.
让我为你介绍保罗·塔夫书中提到的另一个人。她是纳丁·伯克·哈里斯（Nadine Burke Harris）医生。2007年，她在旧金山湾景-猎人角（Bayview-Hunters Point）为孩子们开办了一家诊所。她在那里开办诊所，是因为像那样的贫困少数族裔社区通常比其他社区的健康状况要差。她是一位理想主义的年轻黑人医生。她想对此有所作为。她还拥有公共卫生硕士学位。但压力及其对儿童的影响还不在她的视野中。
I thought that if we kind of did the basic stuff-- if we worked on asthma, hospitalization rates and immunization rates and obesity treatment-- those would be the big public health things that we would need to do to make a difference in this community.
我原以为，如果我们做一些基础工作——如果我们解决哮喘、住院率、免疫接种率和肥胖症治疗——那将是我们在这个社区做出改变所需的重大公共卫生事项。
And what I found in my daily practice was that a lot of folks were sending me kids and saying, you know, "Oh, Dr. Burke, Bobby's got ADHD. Can you put him on Ritalin? Or can you put him on some kind of medication?"
我在日常实践中发现，很多人送孩子来找我说，“哦，伯克医生，鲍比（Bobby）得了多动症（ADHD）。你能给他开利他林吗？或者你能给他开某种药物吗？”
But when I did my job and did an actual history and physical, which is what doctors are supposed to do, what I found was most of these kids really didn't have ADHD. And most of these kids had issues associated with trauma.
但当我完成我的工作，做了医生应该做的病史和身体检查时，我发现这些孩子中的大多数并没有多动症。他们中的大多数有与创伤相关的问题。
Let me ask you to talk a little bit about the kind of trauma you're talking about. What was going on in their lives?
我想请你谈谈你所说的创伤类型。他们的生活中发生了什么？
Yeah, so as a pediatrician, I feel like I had the opportunity to hear some of the real story. But we're talking about kids who are witnessing violence on a daily basis. And some of it was domestic violence. Just domestic violence like you wouldn't believe.
是的，作为儿科医生，我觉得我有机会听到一些真实的故事。但我们谈论的是那些每天都在目睹暴力的孩子。其中一些是家庭暴力。那种你简直无法相信的家庭暴力。
I had a family-- you know, sometimes it's almost mundane things, a family who leave the house, and they are boarding up their own windows because they're afraid that their neighbors will come in and rob them. I had a family where, not only did their neighbors rob them, they took everything, including the food in the fridge and the toilet paper off the roll. Right?
我有个家庭——你知道，有时候这几乎是些平凡的小事，一个家庭离开房子时，他们会把自己的窗户封死，因为他们害怕邻居会进来抢劫他们。我有个家庭，邻居不仅抢劫了他们，还拿走了所有东西，包括冰箱里的食物和卷纸架上的卫生纸。对吧？
Wow.
哇。
Someone really robs you when they take your toilet paper.
当有人拿走你的卫生纸时，那真是抢劫。
She started to believe that there was some connection between the terrible situations these kids were living through and the symptoms they showed up with-- headaches, abdominal pain, difficulty with digestion. One girl's hair started falling out. Some little kids had a medical condition called failure to thrive where they didn't grow well.
她开始相信，这些孩子经历的可怕处境与他们表现出来的症状——头痛、腹痛、消化困难——之间存在某种联系。一个女孩开始掉头发。一些小孩患有一种叫“生长迟缓”的疾病，导致发育不良。
But nothing in her medical training or her public health training explained this. So she researched till she found this big, authoritative study that followed over 17,000 patients from San Diego HMO that showed that people who had adverse childhood experiences when they were little ended up with worse health that continued into adulthood.
但她的医学培训或公共卫生培训中没有任何东西能解释这一点。所以她深入研究，直到她找到那项覆盖圣地亚哥健康维护组织（HMO）超过17,000名患者的大型权威研究，该研究显示，小时候经历过不利童年经历的人，其健康状况在成年后依然较差。
She says that for her, it was like that scene in The Matrix when Neo suddenly understands everything about the world. And as we talked, she was actually able to rattle off their findings from memory. She said, if you had enough difficult childhood experiences--
她说，这对她来说，就像《黑客帝国》（The Matrix）里尼奥（Neo）突然理解了世界万物的那一幕。当我们交谈时，她实际上能够凭记忆背诵出研究结果。她说，如果你经历过足够多的童年困难——
You were two and a half times as likely to develop chronic obstructive pulmonary disease in adulthood, twice as likely to have heart disease, two and a half times as likely to have hepatitis, four and a half times as likely to be depressed, 12 times as likely to attempt suicide.
你成年后患慢性阻塞性肺病的几率是常人的2.5倍，患心脏病的几率是2倍，患肝炎的几率是2.5倍，患抑郁症的几率是4.5倍，尝试自杀的几率是12倍。
But in addition to all the bad things that are likely to happen to them as adults, there's also the effect that long-term stress has on them when they're still kids, especially on their brains and their ability to learn.
但除了成年后可能发生的坏事之外，长期压力对他们尚在童年时的影响也很大，特别是在大脑和学习能力方面。
If you look on the molecular level, you're walking through the forest and you see a bear, right? So you can either fight the bear or run from the bear. That's kind of your fight or flight system. Right?
如果你从分子层面看，你在森林里散步，看到了一只熊，对吧？所以你要么打熊，要么从熊身边逃跑。这就是所谓的战斗或逃跑系统。对吧？
Right.
对。
And your body releases a ton of adrenalin, right? Which is your short-term stress hormone, and something else called cortisol, which tends to be more of a long-term stress hormone. And this dilates your pupils, gets your heart beating fast. Your skin gets cold and clammy. That's because you're shunting blood from anywhere that isn't absolutely necessary to the muscles that you need to be able to run from that bear.
你的身体释放大量的肾上腺素，对吧？这是你的短期压力荷尔蒙，还有另一种叫做皮质醇的东西，往往更偏向于长期压力荷尔蒙。这会使你的瞳孔放大，让心脏快速跳动。你的皮肤变得又冷又粘。那是因为你正在将血液从任何并非绝对必要的地方转移到你逃避那只熊所需的肌肉上。
The other thing that it does-- now, you can imagine that if you're about to fight a bear, you need some gumption to fight that bear, right? So it kind of shuts off the thinking portion of your brain, right? That executive function cognitive part. And it turns on the real primal aggression and the things that you need to be able to think that you're going to go into a fight with a bear and come out on the winning side.
它做的另一件事——现在，你可以想象，如果你要和一只熊搏斗，你需要一些胆量来对抗那只熊，对吧？所以它会关闭你大脑中负责思考的部分，对吧？那种执行功能认知部分。然后它会开启原始的攻击性以及你需要去面对一只熊搏斗并获胜所需的东西。
Yeah.
对。
And that's really good if you're in a forest and there's a bear. The problem is when that bear comes home from the bar every night. Right? And for a lot of these kids, what happens is that this system, this fight or flight response, which is an emergency response in your body, it's activated over and over and over again. And so that's what we were seeing in the kids that I was caring for.
如果你在森林里且有一只熊，那确实很好。问题在于，当那只熊每天晚上从酒吧回家时。对吧？对于很多孩子来说，发生的事情是，这个系统，这个战斗或逃跑反应，作为一个身体的紧急反应，被一遍又一遍地激活。所以这就是我在照顾那些孩子时所看到的。
When the brain does something over and over and over again, it creates pathways that get more and more ingrained. So this kind of repeated stress affects the development of these kids' brains. And especially affected in this situation is a specific part of the brain that's called the prefrontal cortex, which is where a lot of these non-cognitive skills happen-- self-control and impulse control, certain kinds of memory and reasoning. Skills they call executive functions.
当大脑一遍又一遍地做某件事时，它会创造出越来越根深蒂固的通路。所以这种反复的压力会影响这些孩子的大脑发育。在这种情况下，受影响特别严重的是大脑中被称为前额叶皮层的一部分，这是很多非认知技能发生的地方——自我控制、冲动控制、某些记忆和推理。也就是他们所说的执行功能。
If you're in a constant state of emergency, that part of your brain just doesn't develop the same. Doctors can see the differences on brain scans. Dr. Burke Harris says that for these kids, the bear basically never goes away. They still feel its effects even when they're just trying to sit there quietly in English class.
如果你处于持续的紧急状态，你大脑的那部分发育就不会一样。医生可以通过脑部扫描看到差异。伯克·哈里斯医生说，对于这些孩子来说，那只熊基本上从未消失。即使当他们只是试图在英语课上安静地坐着时，他们仍能感觉到它的影响。
And if right at that moment someone asks you, "Oh, could you please diagram this sentence? Or could you please divide two complex numbers?" You'd be like, what are you talking about? And so that's what we were seeing in the kids that I was caring for, is that a lot of them had a terrible time paying attention. They have a hard time sitting still.
如果就在那一刻，有人问你，“哦，你能把这个句子分解一下吗？或者你能除这两个复数吗？”你会觉得，你在说什么？这就是我在照顾那些孩子时所看到的，他们很多人注意力极难集中，很难安稳地坐着。
And you hear about this in lots of schools. Head Start teachers in one survey said that over a fourth of their low income students had serious self-control and behavior problems. Nadine Burke Harris says that it's true for her patients, the ones with adverse childhood experiences like neglect, domestic violence, a parent with mental illness or substance abuse.
你在很多学校都会听到这种情况。Head Start教师在一项调查中表示，超过四分之一的低收入学生有严重的自我控制和行为问题。纳丁·伯克·哈里斯说，这对她的患者来说也是真实的，那些有忽视、家庭暴力、父母患有精神疾病或药物滥用等不利童年经历的孩子。
For our kids, if they had four or more adverse childhood experiences, their odds of having learning or behavior problems in school was 32 times as high as kids who had no adverse childhood experiences.
对于我们的孩子来说，如果他们有四种或更多的不利童年经历，他们在学校出现学习或行为问题的几率是那些没有不利童年经历的孩子的32倍。
Paul Tough writes about a number of teenagers and how this plays out for them. One of them is a girl who he met when she was 17, Kewauna Lerma.
保罗·塔夫写了一些青少年以及这对他们有何影响的事情。其中之一是他17岁时遇到的一个女孩，凯瓦纳·勒玛（Kewauna Lerma）。
She had a really chaotic childhood. Her parents split up. She moved around a lot. She was homeless for a while. Just all the bad things that happen to poor kids were happening to her.
她童年非常混乱。父母分开了。她经常搬家。有一段时间她无家可归。贫困孩子经历的所有坏事都在她身上发生了。
The first 10 years of my life was really messed up.
我生命的前10年真的是一团糟。
This is Kewauna. She came into the studio for this radio story to talk with me and Paul.
这就是凯瓦纳。她来到演播室，和我和保罗谈论这个广播故事。
Because it was like my mom, for five years, she was going to place to place, sleeping wherever she could sleep at, you know. And when I was born, my mom and my father, they really couldn't take care of another child or whatever.
因为就像我妈妈，五年间，她居无定所，能在哪睡就在哪睡，你知道。当我出生时，我的父母真的无法照顾另一个孩子之类的。
It's so many different incidents I remember. It's hard to state on one.
我记得很多不同的事件。很难只挑一件说。
When you think back on those times, do you think of that as like, you were mostly happy most of the time? What was it like for you?
当你回想起那些时光时，你会认为那是你大部分时间都很快乐吗？那对你来说是什么感觉？
No, I was never happy. I was never happy, because I was just an angry child. And I really don't understand what I was angry about. I can't even remember what I was angry about.
不，我从来不快乐。我从来不快乐，因为我只是个愤怒的孩子。我真的不明白我在为什么愤怒。我甚至不记得我在为什么愤怒了。
And so she had trouble in all kinds of ways. And the two biggest ways that she had trouble were ones that, I think anyway, had a lot to do with her brain development. One is that she had a really bad temper, bad impulse control. She would just kind of shut down. And she couldn't see anything. And she would just go into these rages. And that was a real problem, especially in school.
所以她在各方面都有问题。而她遇到的两个最大的问题，我想 anyway，与她的大脑发育有很大关系。一是她的脾气非常暴躁，冲动控制能力很差。她会直接关闭自己，什么也看不见，然后陷入这种愤怒中。这真的是个大问题，特别是在学校。
I can't even remember this particular incident when we was in that classroom.
我甚至不记得我们在那间教室里的那次特定事件。
Kewauna got into lots of fights. For instance, with one girl  at school who got to her, Kewauna told me, "like a bug crawling under your sweater."
凯瓦纳经常打架。例如，学校里的一个女孩惹恼了她，凯瓦纳告诉我，“就像一只虫子爬进你的毛衣里。”
One time I did that, she just made me so mad, I just started screaming everything I could in class. I just got up like I was a terminator or something. And I was about to attack her. And I was like screaming. And I just like stopped the whole classroom or whatever. And Mr. Coleman--
有一次我确实那样做了，她让我太生气了，我就开始在课堂上大喊大叫。我就像终结者什么的站起来。我正要攻击她。我尖叫着。我就像让整个课堂停了下来什么的。然后科尔曼老师——
This is the dean of her high school, Mr. Coleman.
这是她的高中主任，科尔曼老师。
He told me, "Miss Lerma, stop cussing." But when I blank out, I'm not thinking about nobody that's right here in front of me. I see him in front of me just doing this. And he told me about that. He was like, you blanked out. It was like you didn't see me. He was like, I was saying, "Miss Lerma, stop cussing. And you just kept on cussing." And I was like, I don't know. I blank out.
他告诉我，“勒玛小姐，停止辱骂。”但当我断片的时候，我根本没在想眼前的人是谁。我看到他在我面前做这个动作。他告诉我那件事。他说，你断片了。就像你根本没看见我一样。他说，我说，“勒玛小姐，停止辱骂。而你一直不停地辱骂。”我说，我不知道。我断片了。
She was one of those kids who was always fighting with teachers, talking back--
她是那种总是和老师打架、顶嘴的孩子——
She told me that, I think, in her sixth grade year, she got 72 referrals, meaning she was sent to the principal 72 times. And as a result, she was sent into the slow class. She was put into this class where all the kids do poorly.
她告诉我，我想是在她六年级的时候，她被转介了72次，意味着她被送去校长办公室72次。结果，她被送进了慢班。她被放进了所有成绩不好的孩子都在的那种班。
It was called the Wings program?
那叫“翅膀”项目（Wings program）吗？
Exactly, the Wings program. And she still talks about how it was kind of devastating for her emotionally to be put in that class.
没错，“翅膀”项目。她仍然提到被放进那个班级对她在情感上有多么摧毁。
So I got put in this program called Wings, and I was embarrassed.
所以我被放进了一个叫“翅膀”的项目，我很尴尬。
You were embarrassed because you just felt like?
你感到尴尬是因为你只是觉得？
Because we were retarded. That's was we was called. It wasn't like-- I'm not going to beat around a bush. I'm not going to say like, "we were just under-performing." No. We were retarded. That's what we got called. That's what we were seen as. That's what it was.
因为我们是白痴（retarded）。那就是我们被叫的名字。我不是——我不会兜圈子。我不会说“我们只是表现不佳”。不。我们是白痴。那就是我们被叫的。那就是我们被视为的样子。事实就是这样。
And was the idea in Wings that you were supposed to just go there for a while and get your remedial stuff and then get back in your regular class? What were they doing in Wings?
那么在“翅膀”里的想法是你应该去那里待一段时间，补习一下基础课，然后回到常规班级吗？他们在“翅膀”里做什么？
We wasn't doing nothing. That's what they said we were going to be doing. But most times, we would play video games, eat popcorn. Nobody never did-- we didn't do anything. It was like they were just carrying us to our tables every day. I felt like they treated us like something was wrong with us or something. They were like, "You want to play the video game? Here you go. Let's play a video game." I can't do that in my other class, so why are we doing it here, you know?
我们什么都没做。他们说我们会做点什么。但大多数时候，我们就是打电子游戏、吃爆米花。没人——我们什么也没做。感觉他们每天只是把我们带到桌子旁。我觉得他们对待我们就像我们有毛病一样。他们会说，“想玩电子游戏吗？给你。我们玩游戏吧。”我在其他班级做不到，那为什么我们在这里要做这个呢，你知道？
Paul Tough says that what happened to Kewauna happens to kids all the time.
保罗·塔夫说，凯瓦纳身上发生的事一直在孩子们身上重演。
Where the early stresses and problems that had to do with her family and had to do with how her parents were dealing with life all were creating in her brain a set of problems that, then when she got into the school system, they didn't have a way to deal with it except for putting her into the slow class, except for saying, "You're a problem child."
早期与她家庭相关的压力和问题，以及她父母处理生活的方式，都在她大脑中制造了一系列问题，然后当她进入学校系统时，他们除了把她放进慢班，除了说“你是个问题儿童”之外，别无他法。
Which raises the question, what else could the school system do for a kid like this? What will work?
这就提出了一个问题，学校系统还能为这样的孩子做什么？什么会有效？
Well, James Heckman, the economist you heard earlier who's studying these non-cognitive skills, says that one advantage of working with non-cognitive skills is that they can be learned. That's not true for cognitive ability, for intelligence the way we usually think of it, like your intelligence on an IQ test.
嗯，刚才你听到的那位研究非认知技能的经济学家詹姆斯·赫克曼说，处理非认知技能的一个优势是它们是可以被学习的。这对于认知能力，对于我们通常理解的智力，比如你在智商测试中的智力，是不适用的。
Well cognitive, pure IQ tends to be pretty hardened, at least what's called rank stability. If you're a top dog in the distribution at age 10, you're probably going to be top dog at age 30.
纯粹的认知智商往往相当僵化，至少是所谓的排名稳定性。如果你在10岁时处于排名的顶端，你可能在30岁时依然处于顶端。
Versus non-cognitive skills, he says.
对比非认知技能，他说。
Social skills, personality traits, the ability to stay on task-- these can be taught. And these can be taught at later ages. And there's a malleability there that actually offers a new perspective on social policy-- how social policy might redirect itself towards those more malleable soft skills.
社交技能、人格特质、保持任务的能力——这些是可以教授的。而且可以在较晚的年龄段教授。这具有一定的可塑性，实际上为社会政策提供了新的视角——社会政策可能如何重新引导向那些更具可塑性的软技能。
And so with that in mind, programs and experiments have sprung up to try to change kids' lives by teaching these non-cognitive skills. And Paul Tough documents a bunch of these in his book. What's striking, Tough says, is how simple some of the interventions are. Many of them basically come down to having a coach for kids to teach them resilience and optimism and grit in certain situations.
考虑到这一点，各种旨在通过教授这些非认知技能来改变孩子生活的项目和实验如雨后春笋般涌现。保罗·塔夫在他的书中记录了许多这类项目。塔夫说，引人注目的是，其中一些干预措施竟然如此简单。它们中很多基本上归结为为孩子们提供教练，教他们在特定情况下保持韧性、乐观和坚毅。
There are some studies where they've taken kids and given them-- taken kids, I think, in middle school and given them a college mentor. And this college mentor would work with these kids not very intensively, like meeting with them a couple of times a year. And the only thing that they would say to them, the only message that they would give to them, is simply this idea that, "You know, scientists have studied intelligence. And they've found that you can improve your intelligence. So you should just think about that as you're going through your day."
有一些研究，他们挑选了孩子，为他们提供——我想是初中的孩子，给他们找了一个大学生导师。这位大学生导师并没有非常频繁地与这些孩子互动，比如一年见他们几次。而他们唯一会告诉他们的信息，唯一传递的信息就是这个简单的想法：“你知道，科学家们研究过智力。他们发现你可以提高你的智力。所以你在度过一天时，就这么想吧。”
Whether or not they're right that they can improve their intelligence, if you think that, especially when you're a kid, when you're a teenager, you do way better at school. It gives you this sort of confidence, this optimism, this ability to try new things, to push yourself harder.
不管他们说能提高智力是对是错，如果你这么想，特别是当你还是个孩子、还是个少年的时候，你在学校的表现就会好得多。这给了你一种自信、乐观，以及尝试新事物、更加鞭策自己的能力。
And one of the things that I find most interesting about this study is that it's the kids who have sort of cultural reasons to be anxious about their skills who are most affected by the message.
而在我看来，这项研究中最有趣的一点是，那些在文化上容易对自己的技能感到焦虑的孩子，受这种信息的影响最大。
So especially girls and math-- you know, girls do great on math until they get to middle school. And then they start becoming socially anxious. And they tend to fall apart. When they hear this message, the girls catch up to the boys entirely. They close that gap 100%.
所以特别是女孩和数学——你知道，女孩在初中之前数学都很好。然后她们开始产生社交焦虑。她们往往会崩溃。当她们听到这个信息时，女孩们完全赶上了男孩。她们100%弥补了差距。
100%, meaning the girls' average math test scores were the same as the boys' average math test scores. That is a huge result. Another example of huge payback for a small amount of coaching happens in early childhood. And this one is an intervention with the parents, not with the kids.
100%，意味着女孩的平均数学测试分数与男孩的平均数学测试分数相同。这是一个巨大的成果。在幼儿时期，少量的辅导也能带来巨大回报的另一个例子。这是一个针对家长而非孩子的干预措施。
And to explain this intervention, I'm just going to take a little detour here and tell you about a study that involves rats-- stay with me on this one-- involving rat babies and rat parents. This was done at McGill University Again, here's Paul Tough.
为了解释这种干预，我在这里稍微绕个道，告诉你一个关于老鼠的实验——坚持住，听我说完——涉及鼠宝宝和鼠父母。这同样是在麦吉尔大学（McGill University）完成的。再次请出保罗·塔夫。
What they discovered is that there were certain mother rats called dams, who, in their laboratory, tended to lick and groom their pups more, especially in stressful situations. And for a rat pup, the stressful situation in life, if you're in a lab, is getting picked up by a graduate student, by a scientist. And this is really stressful, understandably, for a rat pup.
他们发现有一些母鼠，在实验室里，它们往往会更多地舔舐和梳理幼崽，特别是在压力大的情况下。对于鼠宝宝来说，如果是在实验室里，生活中的压力情境就是被研究生、被科学家捡起来。这对于鼠宝宝来说确实压力很大，这是可以理解的。
And when they put the rat pups back in the cage, certain rat moms would do this ritual of kind of licking and grooming and soothing their rat pups. And certain moms wouldn't
当他们把鼠宝宝放回笼子里时，一些鼠妈妈会进行那种舔舐、梳理和安抚鼠宝宝的仪式。而一些妈妈则不会。
The researchers wanted to understand what this was about. It seemed significant in some way. So they studied the pups when they grew into adulthood. And they found that the rats that had been licked and groomed were very different from the ones that hadn't been.
研究人员想了解这是关于什么的。它看起来在某种程度上很重要。所以他们研究了那些长大的老鼠。他们发现被舔舐和梳理过的老鼠与那些没有被这样对待过的老鼠有很大不同。
They were more confident. They were better at mazes. They were less fearful. They just did better on all of these different measurements. And what was so interesting and weird about it is that the licking and grooming only happened in the first couple of weeks of life. And then they didn't see their parents at all. And there was this huge difference.
它们更自信。它们跑迷宫更出色。它们更不胆怯。它们在所有这些不同的衡量标准下都表现更好。有趣且古怪的是，舔舐和梳理只发生在生命的最初几周。然后它们根本看不到父母了。但这产生了巨大的差异。
So it really demonstrated two things. One is the power of parenting-- for rats, at least. And the other was how what really matters is early on, at least in a rat's childhood.
所以这确实证明了两件事。一是育儿的力量——至少对老鼠而言。另一件事是真正重要的，至少在老鼠的童年时期，是早期的经历。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
And so what this connected with for a lot of scientists who were more interested in human babies than rat babies, was the research that scientists have done about attachment. This idea that certain parents are able, especially in the first year of a child's life, to form what's called a secure attachment relationship.
所以对于许多对人类婴儿比对鼠宝宝更感兴趣的科学家来说，这与科学家们关于依恋的研究联系在了一起。这个想法是，有些父母，特别是在孩子生命的第一年，能够形成所谓的安全依恋关系。
And this is something a lot of parents have heard of. Attachment is an idea that's been around since the 1950s and '60s. What scientists mean when they talk about it has to do with responsiveness, a parent who--
这是很多父母都听说过的事情。依恋是一个自20世纪50年代和60年代以来就存在的想法。当科学家谈论它时，意思是响应性，一个家长能够——
Reacts to how the child is feeling and helps and comforts them, kind of the human equivalent of licking and grooming, helps when the child is stressed out. That tends to create a secure attachment.
对孩子的感受做出反应，帮助和安慰他们，就像人类版本的舔舐和梳理，在孩子感到压力时提供帮助。这往往能建立安全依恋。
Researchers say that about 2/3 of American kids have a secure attachment, 1/3 don't. And the 2/3 with a secure attachment are more socially competent and confident through their lives. They're better at dealing with other people and making friends. They're better able to deal with setbacks. They're more likely to be engaged in the classroom. They're more likely to graduate high school.
研究人员表示，大约三分之二的美国儿童有安全依恋，三分之一没有。那三分之二有安全依恋的孩子在生活中社交能力更强、更自信。他们更擅长与人交往和交朋友。他们更善于应对挫折。他们更有可能参与课堂活动。他们更有可能高中毕业。
But on top of all these good things that come from attachment, it also has a profound impact on what we're talking about here today-- on non-cognitive skills. If a kid lives in a stressful, chaotic home-- one of those homes where things are bad enough that it can affect their brain development and they don't learn non-cognitive skills-- if kids in that situation have a secure attachment with an empathetic parent, when researchers measured their allostatic load-- the allostatic load is a medical assessment of the effect on their body of stress. They look at blood pressure. They look at the stress hormones in their system and some other factors. What they find is--
但除了依恋带来的所有这些好处外，它对我们今天在这里讨论的内容——非认知技能——也有深远的影响。如果一个孩子生活在充满压力和混乱的家庭中——那种情况糟糕到足以影响他们大脑发育，且他们无法学到非认知技能的家庭——如果这些孩子能与一位有同理心的家长建立安全依恋关系，当研究人员衡量他们的“总负荷”（allostatic load）时——总负荷是对压力给身体造成影响的一种医学评估。他们观察血压。他们观察系统中的压力荷尔蒙以及其他一些因素。他们发现——
That the ones who had that sort of licking and grooming style connection, they didn't have all of those biological effects of early stress. They were mostly OK.
那些拥有那种舔舐和梳理式连接的孩子，并没有表现出早期压力的所有生物学影响。他们大多没问题。
So what does that tell us?
那么这告诉了我们什么？
Well, I think what it tells us is that early stress matters a lot, but that parenting is able to reverse a lot of the effects where they can still be in poverty. They can still be in a pretty stressful environment. But if they have a close relationship with their mother or some other adult, it protects them from the effects of that stuff.
嗯，我认为它告诉我们的是，早期压力非常重要，但育儿能够逆转很多影响，他们仍然可能身处贫困之中。他们仍然可能身处压力很大的环境中。但如果他们与母亲或其他成年人有亲密的联系，这能保护他们免受那些东西的影响。
This, of course, is just science backing up what common sense would tell you anyway. Though there definitely comes a point in reading Paul Tough's book when he's discussing how attachment can protect a kid from the effects of a chaotic home or a bad neighborhood that it is really hard not to think, couldn't somebody just teach this to parents? Parents who don't know how to attach to their kids? Well, it turns out  the answer's yes, and people are doing it.
当然，这只是用科学来支持常识。尽管在阅读保罗·塔夫的书时，当他讨论依恋如何保护孩子免受混乱家庭或恶劣社区影响时，确实到了一个地步，让人很难不去想，难道不能教父母这些吗？那些不知道如何与孩子建立依恋的父母？好吧，答案是肯定的，而且人们正在这样做。
We're gonna do some games today.
我们今天要玩些游戏。
What's this?
这是什么？
Those are Ziploc bags.
那是Ziploc密封袋。
Ziploc bag.
Ziploc袋子。
Yup
没错。
This is a home visit by Simone Smith, who works in a project funded by an Illinois nonprofit called The Ounce of Prevention Fund. She's at the home of Barbara McDonald, who is 19. Her daughter, Aniya, is three. They both live with Barbara's mom on the South Side of Chicago. Simone's been working with Barbara ever since Aniya was a newborn, teaching her basically how to attach.
这是西蒙娜·史密斯（Simone Smith）进行的家访，她在一个由伊利诺伊州非营利组织“盎司预防基金会”（The Ounce of Prevention Fund）资助的项目中工作。她在19岁的芭芭拉·麦克唐纳（Barbara McDonald）家里。她的女儿阿尼娅（Aniya）三岁。她们都和芭芭拉的妈妈一起住在芝加哥南区。西蒙娜从阿尼娅还是新生儿时就一直在指导芭芭拉，教她基本上如何建立依恋。
H is for hand.
H代表手（hand）。
H for hands.
H代表手。
On this visit, they made flash cards for the ABCs. Simone showed Barbara what to do, and then Barbara took over.
在这次访问中，她们制作了字母卡片。西蒙娜展示了该做什么，然后芭芭拉接手了。
O is for owl.
O代表猫头鹰（owl）。
A is for owl.
A代表猫头鹰。
O is for owl.
O代表猫头鹰。
A is for owl.
A代表猫头鹰。
Say O.
说O。
O.
O。
Is owl.
是猫头鹰。
Owl.
猫头鹰。
We do activities together with the mother and the child so that the mother can begin to see the baby in a different light.
我们和母亲与孩子一起做活动，以便母亲能开始以不同的眼光看待婴儿。
Simone Smith, Barbara's coach.
西蒙娜·史密斯，芭芭拉的教练。
And what I've learned is that when the mother can see what their child can do, even the smallest things, they begin to think like, "Oh my god, that's my baby. You know, I helped my baby do that." And that helps them form a better bond and relationship with their baby.
我学到的是，当母亲能看到孩子能做什么时，即使是最小的事情，她们也开始想，“天哪，那是我的孩子。你知道，我帮助我的孩子做到了那一点。”这有助于她们与婴儿建立更好的联结和关系。
Simone's job is to teach the mom how to read what the baby wants, to be more in tuned. To see the infant as somebody you can have a relationship with, which is not how a lot of teenage moms see it as first. They just see their babies as these incomprehensible bundles of need. Barbara says this is definitely how she saw Aniya at first, cutting into her sleep at night.
西蒙娜的工作是教妈妈如何解读宝宝想要什么，变得更加协调。把婴儿看作一个你可以与之建立关系的人，这并不是很多十几岁的妈妈起初的看法。她们只是把宝宝看作这些难以理解的、充满需求的包袱。芭芭拉说起初她绝对是这样看阿尼娅的，晚上还打断她的睡眠。
I had to get up several times within an hour. I was just like, she's just being mean to me!
我一小时内得起床好几次。我当时想，她就是在跟我作对！
Come here to mom. Let me help you. Come here. Let me help you. You're cutting wrong. Come on over here. And we're going to cut together.
来妈妈这。让我帮你。来这。让我帮你。你剪错了。过来这里。我们一起剪。
Barbara, you see how you're all getting along and cooperating? You're always talking about ya'll can't get along?
芭芭拉，你看你们相处得多么融洽和协作？你总是说你们无法相处？
We can't. Look, she wants to take control.
我们做不到。看，她想掌控一切。
That's because she wants to learn.
那是因为她想学习。
Hello, hello. We gotta turn it. We gotta turn the paper.
你好，你好。我们需要转一下。我们需要转动纸张。
She'll get it.
她会学会的。
You gotta follow the lines, OK?
你必须沿着线剪，好吗？
In the beginning, if you just looked at Barbara and her daughter, you would think that that was Barbara's sister. So we had to work on Barbara being more motherly. And then, also because the two were so much alike, Barbara and her daughter, they would often clash. So we had to work on that, and just Barbara learning her daughter's temperament and how to follow her baby's cues.
起初，如果你只看芭芭拉和她女儿，你会以为那是芭芭拉的妹妹。所以我们不得不致力于让芭芭拉表现得更有母性。而且因为两人如此相似，芭芭拉和她女儿经常发生冲突。所以我们不得不处理这个问题，让芭芭拉学习她女儿的脾气，以及如何跟随宝宝的暗示。
So if Aniya wanted to do something on the floor, then Barbara could just get on the floor and do it with her, as opposed to Barbara just wanting to do it on the couch. And then they both just say, "You know what? Forget it. Let's just not do it."
所以如果阿尼娅想在地板上做些什么，芭芭拉就可以在地板上和她一起做，而不是芭芭拉只想在沙发上做。然后她们俩都会说，“你知道吗？算了。我们还是别做了。”
Yep. I came in yesterday with the some food.
没错。我昨天带着一些食物进来。
Mommy, I can do it.
妈妈，我能做。
She took my french fries and told me they was hers after she took them out of my hand!
她拿走了我的炸薯条，在从我手里拿走之后告诉我那是她的！
And what--?
而且什么——？
I just told her I guess they're yours.
我只是告诉她我想它们是你的了。
Mommy, I wanna do it!
妈妈，我想做！
No, I don't want you to cut yourself. You wanna cut yourself?
不，我不想让你剪到自己。你想剪到自己吗？
Yeah.
想。
And I'm gonna cry if you cut yourself.
如果你剪到自己，我会哭的。
This small thing, explaining to Aniya why she doesn't want her to use her scissors by herself, Barbara says she had to learn that from Simone. She didn't just know to do it.
这件小事，向阿尼娅解释为什么她不想让她自己用剪刀，芭芭拉说她必须从西蒙娜那里学到这个。她并不知道该怎么做。
Just simple things like that, like actually talking to her and giving her reasons why. Because she's at that age now that everything's gotta have a reason. And I had to learn the hard-- not the hard way, but I had to learn to like, because I used to just be just like, "No, don't do this." And she's always like, "Why, Mommy?" And I would just be like, "I don't know. Because I said so." But then, she'd just keep asking, "Why?" I used to just tell her, "Just leave me alone because I said so, and don't ask me no more questions."
就是这样简单的事情，比如真正和她交谈并给出理由。因为她现在到了那个年龄，每件事都必须有理由。而我不得不学得很难——不是很难，但我不得不学，因为我以前总是像，“不，别那样做。”而她总是说，“为什么，妈妈？”而我只会说，“我不知道。因为我说了算。”但后来，她会一直问，“为什么？”我以前只会告诉她，“别理我，因为我说了算，别再问我问题了。”
Barbara's gotten close to Aniya. Watching her, she seems like a good mom. And Simone says she's made a lot of progress. If all this works the way it should, even though Aniya might grow up around the stresses and chaos that lots of poor kids grow up with, the attachment she made with Barbara will help protect her. Her allostatic load, the stress on her body and on her brain, will be smaller. And her non-cognitive skills will have a chance to flourish, meaning, theoretically at least, she might do better in school, be more social, more confident.
芭芭拉和阿尼娅变得亲密了。看着她，她似乎是个好妈妈。西蒙娜说她进步很大。如果这一切按预想的那样运作，即使阿尼娅可能是在很多贫困孩子成长的压力和混乱中长大，她与芭芭拉建立的依恋也将有助于保护她。她的总负荷，即对身体和大脑的压力，会变小。她的非认知技能将有机会蓬勃发展，这意味着，至少在理论上，她可能会在学校表现得更好，更善于社交，更自信。
Now, I think we got the best mother-daughter relationship, because she just talk to me. Like I will come in from school, and she'll be like, "How was school, Mommy?" And I just can't wait till I can ask her that, like "How was school?"
现在，我认为我们拥有最好的母女关系，因为她只是跟我说话。比如我从学校回来，她会说，“学校怎么样，妈妈？”我真等不及能那样问她，“学校怎么样？”
I love being with her. She just makes my day. Even on a sad day, she would just do something, and I'd just be like, "You are so silly." And she'd be like, "Mommy likes silly?" And I'd be like, "Yes, I like when you be silly. And I love you."
我喜欢和她在一起。她让我的每一天都很美好。即使在悲伤的日子里，她也会做些什么，我会说，“你真是太傻了。”而她会说，“妈妈喜欢傻傻的？”我会说，“是的，我喜欢你傻傻的样子。我爱你。”
The University of Minnesota study of this kind of program showed that this kind of intervention, a coach working with parents the way that Simone works with Barbara, can lead to 61% percent of children developing a strong attachment to their parent versus just 2% in the control group that didn't get an intervention.
明尼苏达大学关于此类项目的研究表明，这种干预措施，即像西蒙娜指导芭芭拉那样，教练与家长合作，可以使61%的孩子与家长建立牢固的依恋关系，而没有干预的对照组中只有2%。
Well, let's say that nobody put your parents into a program like Ounce of Prevention and you grow up in a stressful home without acquiring these non-cognitive skills. It's affected your brain development. Now, you're a teenager. What can be done for you?
那么，假设没有人把你的父母送进像“盎司预防基金会”这样的项目，而你在一个压力巨大的家庭中长大，没有获得这些非认知技能。这影响了你的大脑发育。现在，你是个少年。你能做什么？
Well, the answer is lots. And like I said earlier, it's amazing how simple some of these interventions are. We will get to them in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
嗯，答案是很多。正如我之前所说，这些干预措施简单得令人惊叹。我们稍后会提到，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today, our Back to School show. We're looking at what children need to learn and talking about this new book by Paul Tough, which makes the case that a whole area of skills called non-cognitive skills are just as important to a child's success as the cognitive skills that our schools are organized around and evaluated on today.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天，我们的开学特别节目。我们正在审视孩子们需要学习什么，并讨论保罗·塔夫的新书，该书指出，一整类被称为非认知技能的能力对于孩子的成功和学校目前围绕并进行评估的认知技能一样重要。
We've arrived at the second half of our show where we turn back to teenagers and back to Kewauna Lerma who you heard from earlier. Paul Tough actually met Kewauna because she caught a lucky break and ended up in a program that was working with Chicago students and coaching them to learn non-cognitive skills.
我们进入了节目的后半段，我们回到青少年，回到你刚才听到的凯瓦纳·勒玛。保罗·塔夫实际上是遇到了凯瓦纳，因为她幸运地进入了一个项目，该项目致力于与芝加哥学生合作，辅导他们学习非认知技能。
But before a program like that could do her much good, there was a much more traditional intervention by her family. It came when she was 15. She got arrested for punching a cop. Yes, punching a cop.
但在这样一个项目能对她产生多大帮助之前，她的家庭进行了更传统的干预。那发生在她15岁时。她因为殴打警察被捕。是的，殴打警察。
She was shorter than five and a half feet. She was 15 years old. She was so aggressive that he called for backup, and they tased her before throwing her into jail. When she got out, her mom took her to her great grandmother's house for a talk.
她身高不到五英尺六英寸。她15岁。她太具有攻击性了，警察不得不请求增援，并在把她扔进监狱前对她使用了泰瑟枪。当她出来时，她妈妈带她去曾祖母家谈话。
So they sat me down. When my grandmother began to talk, that's what kind of made me a little soft, because I'm really sensitive for my great grandmother, because she was the one you could talk to about anything. It was just the main thing that got to me is when it was like tears in the room and stuff. That when I went "Oh, no." Because I'm not good with people that's crying and stuff.
所以她们让我坐下。当我曾祖母开始说话时，那让我有点变软了，因为我对曾祖母真的很敏感，因为她是可以和你谈论任何事的人。最主要的是当房间里有眼泪什么的时，我真的受不了。我当时想“哦，不。”因为我不擅长面对哭泣的人。
They started crying?
她们开始哭了？
Yeah, my mom. When my mom started crying, she just said, "I don't want you to be like me. I don't want you to go through what I had to go through, the mistakes that I had, the suffering, the home to home, the homeless." Because at a point in my time, we were homeless when my father had left us. He was the income. So we became homeless, and he didn't care.
是的，我妈妈。当我妈妈开始哭时，她说：“我不希望你像我一样。我不希望你经历我不得不经历的事，我不希望你犯我犯过的错误，经历那种苦难，流离失所，无家可归。”因为有一段时间，当父亲离开我们时，我们无家可归。他是家庭收入来源。所以我们变得无家可归，而他根本不在乎。
My mom was just talking about, like, "I don't want you to be like me. And I don't want you to go through this stuff I have to go through with my kids, not being able to support my kids." And she said the main thing she wanted me to do also was to listen, because that's something that she didn't do. She didn't listen to her mother. And now, look.
我妈妈当时只是说，“我不希望你像我一样。我不希望你经历我不得不经历的养育孩子的事，无法支持我的孩子。”她说她最希望我做的事也是去倾听，因为那是她没做到的事。她没有听她母亲的话。现在，看看吧。
It was really sincere. It really got through to me, which is the reason why I'm here today.
这真的很真诚。它真的触动了我，这就是为什么我今天能坐在这里的原因。
The changes didn't happen all at once. But in her sophomore year in high school, Kewauna started doing her homework. She stopped skipping class. She didn't hang out with the same people.
改变并非一蹴而就。但在高中二年级时，凯瓦纳开始做家庭作业了。她不再逃课。她不再和以前那些人混在一起。
Freshman year before this talk, her GPA was 1.8. Sophomore year, it was 3.4. And then in her sophomore year, she happened to be at a school where she could sign up for a program called One Goal, which works in 23 high schools in Chicago. It's about 1,300 kids. Not in magnet schools or charter programs, these kids are not the cream of the crop. These are average kids in regular schools that do not send many kids to college. Again, Paul Tough.
谈话前的高一，她的平均成绩（GPA）是1.8。高二，变成了3.4。然后在高二时，她碰巧在一所学校，可以报名参加一个叫“一个目标”（One Goal）的项目，该项目在芝加哥的23所高中运作。大约有1300个孩子。不是磁力学校或特许学校，这些孩子不是精英。他们是普通学校里的普通孩子，这些学校没有多少学生能上大学。再次重申，保罗·塔夫。
And they're very much using the research into non-cognitive skills to figure out an intervention for these kids, to help kids really explicitly develop these non-cognitive skills. The term they use is leadership principles-- ambition, professionalism, resourcefulness, resilience-- that they just spend a couple years talking to these kids about and explaining to them how it's going to be important in college.
他们非常利用对非认知技能的研究来为这些孩子设计干预措施，以帮助孩子真正明确地发展这些非认知技能。他们使用的术语是领导力原则——雄心、职业素养、足智多谋、韧性——他们花几年时间与这些孩子讨论，并向他们解释这些在大学里会有多重要。
Now, you made some recordings when you were writing your book of the class. And I should say, these weren't broadcast quality. You were just making them to keep them for yourself. But they're good enough that you can actually hear what's happening. So here's one of those.
现在，你在写书时录了一些课上的录音。我应该说，这些不是广播质量。你只是录下来给自己保留。但它们效果不错，实际上你能听到发生了什么。所以这里是其中一个。
This is the part where you need to start being resourceful. It can't be, "Mrs. Steffel, can you call?" You are making the phone call. I want to make sure that's clear.
这是你需要开始变得足智多谋的部分。不能总是，“斯特费尔夫人，你能打个电话吗？”是你自己在打电话。我想确保这一点很清楚。
So what you're hearing is Kewauna's teacher, a woman named Michelle Steffel. There are lots of things that kids are learning in this class. But in some ways, when I would sit in the One Goal classroom, it felt like this kind of ongoing group therapy session. I don't think they would want me to say that, because it sounds too--
所以你听到的是凯瓦纳的老师，一位叫米歇尔·斯特费尔（Michelle Steffel）的女士。孩子们在这个班里学的东西很多。但在某种程度上，当我坐在“一个目标”的教室里时，感觉就像这种持续不断的团体治疗。我不认为他们会想让我这么说，因为它听起来太——
Touchy feely.
感性了。
Touchy feely. Yeah. But really, that is what makes a huge difference for these kids is learning these psychological skills. And when they get to college, that's what's going to make a difference.
感性。是的。但说真的，这就是这些孩子巨大的区别所在——学习这些心理技能。当他们上大学时，这就是将产生影响的地方。
It's OK to be scared. It's OK to kind of stumble and fall along the way. And you should. It's not going to be easy. It shouldn't be easy. This is your life, OK? It's not going to be a bed of roses. OK?
害怕没关系。一路上跌跌撞撞也是正常的。而且你应该如此。这不会容易。也不应该容易。这是你的人生，好吗？生活不会是一床玫瑰。好吗？
One Goal's premise is it's going to be difficult to make up for how far behind these kids are in their cognitive skills, in traditional test scores and all that. When Kewauna first took a practice ACT test for college, she scored an 11, putting her in the bottom one percentile of everyone who took the ACT that year. After months of study, she said she went up one point.
“一个目标”的前提是，弥补这些孩子在认知技能、传统考试成绩等方面的落后是很难的。当凯瓦纳第一次参加大学ACT练习考试时，她得了11分，让她处于当年所有参加ACT考试的人的后1%。经过几个月的学习，她说她提高了一分。
But One Goal could teach her non-cognitive skills-- how to be resourceful, how to rebound from a setback, how to control herself and not get into fights-- plus concrete skills that would be useful, like how to present yourself, how to network. Kewauna never used to ask questions in class. She thought her questions were dumb. So she had to learn how to do that.
但“一个目标”可以教她非认知技能——如何足智多谋、如何从挫折中反弹、如何自我控制而不打架——再加上会有用的具体技能，比如如何展示自己、如何建立人脉。凯瓦纳以前从不在课堂上提问。她认为她的问题很蠢。所以她必须学习如何做到这一点。
She ended up with an ACT score of 15, which, combined with a 4.1 grade point average in her junior and senior years, got her into college-- Western Illinois University in Macomb. She was a freshman last year.
她最终ACT得了15分，加上高三和高四4.1的GPA，这让她进入了大学——马科姆（Macomb）的西伊利诺伊大学。去年她是大一新生。
Paul Tough has stayed in touch with her. And he says her training paid off. In fact, he says it's hard to imagine how she would have gotten to college and made it through freshman year without that training. Non-cognitive traits like grit and self-control are even more important in college than in high school.
保罗·塔夫一直与她保持联系。他说她的训练得到了回报。事实上，他说很难想象如果没有那种训练，她会如何考上大学并度过大一。像坚毅和自我控制这样的非认知特质在大学里比在高中更重要。
And then the other thing that I think has made a huge difference for her at college especially is this resourcefulness, is this sense that she has of like, "I'm starting from behind. I need to do everything. I need to get everything on this campus working for me," which I think is not a way that most kids think when they arrive on campus, and definitely not kids from the South Side of Chicago.
而且我认为对她而言，特别是在大学里产生的巨大影响的另一件事是这种足智多谋，是她拥有的那种感觉，即“我起步落后了。我需要做一切。我需要让这个校园里的一切为我所用”，我认为这不是大多数孩子在刚到校园时会想到的方式，更别提芝加哥南区的孩子了。
The first thing I did when I first got to every class, I introduced myself. First-- no, first, I sat in the front. If everybody else was sitting in the back, no. I sat in the front, like right on it. Like I'm nearly touching your desk and let them know, let them see my face, and let them remember it. And then after I go, the first step is to make sure they see your face, like they know who you are. As long as they know who you are.
我第一件事就是在每堂课开始时，做自我介绍。首先——不，首先，我坐在前面。如果其他人都坐在后面，不。我坐在前面，直接在那儿。我几乎摸到了你的桌子，让老师注意，让他们看到我的脸，让他们记住它。然后我去之后，第一步是确保他们看到你的脸，让他们知道你是谁。只要他们知道你是谁就行。
And I always, like after class or before class, I introduce myself. Ask them about their office hours. And have like a little calendar on my wall and say, "This day." I always did a check-in to see how I was doing.
我总是，在课后或课前，做自我介绍。询问他们的办公时间。墙上贴个小日历说，“这一天。”我总是做个签到，看看我做得如何。
I will go to a teacher. I will go to a professor and get help. I have no shame in my game no more.
我会去找老师。我会去找教授寻求帮助。我再也不以寻求帮助为耻了。
Kewauna's instructor from One Goal stayed in touch with her and the other students from the class all through their first year of college. This was part of the plan, because it's so common for kids to drop out of college, especially for kids from poor neighborhoods.
“一个目标”的指导员与凯瓦纳和其他学生在整个大一期间保持了联系。这是计划的一部分，因为孩子们辍学太常见了，特别是来自贫困社区的孩子。
This is one the surprising things that Paul Tough says that he learned as he wrote this book. The United States used to have a higher percentage of its young people graduate from college than any other country. Now, we're not even close.
这是保罗·塔夫在写这本书时学到的令人惊讶的事情之一。美国曾经有更高比例的年轻人从大学毕业，超过任何其他国家。现在，我们甚至都比不上了。
We're still doing pretty decently in terms of the number-- the percentage of kids, the percentage of say 18-year-olds, who go to college. The problem is--
我们仍然在人数方面表现相当体面——孩子的比例，即18岁上大学的比例。问题是——
Who enroll.
入学的人。
Who enroll, right. Who just show up there on the first day of school. But we also have the highest dropout rate in the world.
入学的人，对吧。那些第一天上学就出现在那里的人。但我们也有世界上最高的辍学率。
I'm just going to pause because that seems worth repeating. The United States has the highest college dropout rate in the industrialized world.
我要暂停一下，因为这值得重复。美国拥有工业化国家中最高的大学辍学率。
It's an issue that we haven't, even in education policy circles, we haven't paid any attention to before very recently. Nobody was really focusing on it. We're very focused on getting kids to college.
这是一个我们之前，甚至在教育政策圈内，直到最近才注意到，之前根本没注意的问题。没有人真正关注它。我们非常专注于送孩子上大学。
Of 128 students who signed up for One Goal at the same time as Kewauna, 85% of them have made it through their freshman year and are now back in school this fall as sophomores. Of course, they're still not done. Nationally, only about 58% of kids who start college end up graduating in six years or fewer.
在与凯瓦纳同时报名参加“一个目标”的128名学生中，85%的人完成了大一学业，今年秋天作为大二学生回到了学校。当然，他们还没有毕业。在全国范围内，只有大约58%开始上大学的孩子能在六年或更短时间内毕业。
But remember, Kewauna and these other kids in One Goal are average Chicago public high school students. They're not a select group. So the 85% is especially impressive. A University of Chicago study a few years ago showed that only 8% of high school freshman in Chicago will get a four year degree from college-- 8%.
但请记住，凯瓦纳和“一个目标”里的这些孩子是普通的芝加哥公立高中学生。他们不是精选出来的。所以85%特别令人印象深刻。芝加哥大学几年前的一项研究显示，芝加哥只有8%的高中一年级学生能获得大学四年制学位——8%。
And of course, this is the hope that Heckman and other educators and researchers have for these non-cognitive skills, that programs like One Goal can teach them to kids like Kewauna, making those kids capable of seizing a better future for themselves.
当然，这就是赫克曼和其他教育工作者及研究人员对这些非认知技能寄予的希望，即“一个目标”这样的项目可以教给像凯瓦纳这样的孩子，使这些孩子有能力为自己抓住一个更好的未来。
And this, I think, just changes the way we think about poverty and human opportunity and what can we do to open up more possibilities to more people.
我认为这改变了我们对贫困、人类机会以及我们能做些什么来为更多人开启更多可能性的思考方式。
When James Heckman talks about this stuff-- you know, economists can be such a sober, cautious bunch-- he can sound positively Utopian.
当詹姆斯·赫克曼谈论这些时——你知道，经济学家可以是非常清醒、谨慎的一群人——他听起来绝对是乌托邦式的。
I think there's just a general question, which this whole research is about, which is, what are the determinants of human success? How fixed are these determinants? How much can you change them? How much can you bolster them? How much social policy can actually influence those? To me, that's extraordinarily interesting.
我认为有一个一般性的问题，也是这项研究的核心，那就是，人类成功的决定因素是什么？这些决定因素有多固定？你能改变多少？你能加强多少？社会政策实际上能在多大程度上影响这些？对我来说，这非常有趣。
It's so interesting when you talk about this, because I feel like there's this vision of human perfectibility. Like, oh, our goal is we're going to make people so they'll be more successful and happy. Most of us don't even think about that as a possibility, because that goal is so big.
当你谈论这个时非常有趣，因为我觉得这有一种人类完美主义的愿景。就像，哦，我们的目标是我们会让人们变得更成功、更快乐。我们大多数人甚至没想过这是一种可能性，因为那个目标太大了。
Well, but I think one of the reasons why people don't think it's a possibility is they think these traits are fixed at birth or fixed so early there's not much we can do about it.
嗯，但我认为人们不认为这是可能的原因之一是他们认为这些特质在出生时就固定了，或者固定得太早，我们做不了什么。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think what we've learned is that these human capabilities can be shaped. And as an economist, what I like about it is that it has this possibility of reducing inequality, but not doing it through the standard mechanism of just handing out money and transfers from the rich to the poor. That's ancient.
而且我认为我们学到的是，这些人类能力是可以被塑造的。而且作为经济学家，我喜欢它的一点是，它有可能减少不平等，但不是通过仅仅从富人向穷人分发金钱和转移支付的标准机制。那太古老了。
The idea is you make the poor highly capable. That there really is a possibility of giving people more possibilities. That there really is the chance of improving their capabilities.
这个想法是让你使穷人变得非常有能力。确实存在给人们更多可能性的可能性。确实存在提高他们能力的机会。
And I'm personally very excited by that. And a lot of the evidence comes together, whether it's neuroscience, psychology, economics. It's the confluence of these things. There are these happy times in science and social science and knowledge where different strands come together. And I think we're at such a time.
而且我个人对此感到非常兴奋。而且很多证据汇聚在一起，无论是神经科学、心理学还是经济学。这些是科学、社会科学和知识中的快乐时光，不同的线索汇聚在一起。而且我认为我们正处于这样的时刻。
James Heckman. Paul Tough's book about all this is called How Children Succeed : Grit, Curiosity , and the Hidden Power of Character .
詹姆斯·赫克曼。保罗·塔夫关于这一切的书叫《孩子们如何成功：坚毅、好奇心与品格的隐藏力量》（How Children Succeed: Grit, Curiosity, and the Hidden Power of Character）。
[MUSIC - "YOU DON'T LEARN THAT IN SCHOOL" BY LOUIS ARMSTRONG]
[音乐 - 路易斯·阿姆斯特朗的《你不会在学校学到这个》（YOU DON'T LEARN THAT IN SCHOOL）]
Well, our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, and myself with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer's Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our operations director. Production help from Tarek Fouda. Emily Condon and Elise Bergerson do everything else that there is to do around here.
嗯，我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、乔纳森·门吉瓦（Jonathan Menjivar）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。塔雷克·福达（Tarek Fouda）提供制作帮助。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）和埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）负责这里所有其他需要做的事情。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. The film that our radio show made, Sleepwalk With Me , expands to over 100 cities this weekend. Details about exactly where to see it at our website, thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的广播节目制作的电影《梦游症》（Sleepwalk With Me），本周末将在超过100个城市公映。查看确切放映地点的详情请访问我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org。
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia. Oh, hey! Torey, hey. You're here. Listen, I'm just, uh, finishing the show. You can see I'm finishing the show. But we totally have to talk. Let's talk. I'm going to be done here soon. Just give me 10 minutes.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生负责。哦，嘿！托里，嘿。你在这儿。听着，我只是，呃，在结束节目。你可以看到我在结束节目。但我们绝对需要谈谈。我们谈谈吧。我马上就要结束了。给我10分钟就好。
10 minutes! 10 minutes! Aw, 10 minutes!
10分钟！10分钟！哎，10分钟！
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着《美国生活》的更多故事回来。
10 minutes! 10 minutes! 10 minutes!
10分钟！10分钟！10分钟！
[MUSIC - "BACK TO SCHOOL AGAIN" BY MOROCCO MUZIK MAKERS]
[音乐 - 摩洛哥音乐制造者的《再次回到学校》（BACK TO SCHOOL AGAIN）]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。